Коли бабуся Неделька готує свою випічку,
це завжди ніби маленьке свято.
Антонела та її сестричка Анна спостерігають,
як бабуся впевненими рухами,
ніби без особливих зусиль, вимішує тісто.
Бачили це вже сотні разів, але щоразу це щось особливе.
А як смачно! Справді ніби свято.
Хоча святкувати нічого.
Антонела знає: незабаром вони вже не їстимуть бабусиної здоби,
бо зовсім скоро вона зі своєю мамою та сестрою
переїдуть у Німеччину, до свого тата Стєпана.
Далеко від Хорватії та невеликого господарства
її дідуся та бабусі.
Ті заледве дають собі раду з роботою, відколи
їхні сини виїхали на заробітки за кордон.
Дівчинка страшенно сумує за батьком.
Мама Маріяна з важким серцем залишає рідне село.
- Нема нічого гіршого, як покинути свою сім'ю,
своїх батьків, братів, сестер. Тоді ти бачитимеш їх,
мабуть, лише раз або два на рік. Це дуже важко.
Але я пристосуюся до життя в іншій країні, аби
моя власна сім'я могла бути разом.
Коли Антонела вранці йде до школи, її шлях
пролягає через маленьке село Бук.
У такі дні, як цей, воно виглядає, як маленький рай.
На головній вулиці дівчинка зустрічає
кількох однокласників. Разом вони долають
останні метри до сільської школи.
23 школярі навчаються тут у чотирьох класах.
Поки що, бо з року в рік дітей стає дедалі менше.
Директор школи, який опікується школами
регіону Плетерніца, дуже занепокоєний.
- Коли я починав 15 років тому, ми мали загалом
1400 школярів. Тепер лише 756.
Кількість дітей стрімко впала не лише
в нашому регіоні, але й у цілій Славонії.
Люди масово виїжджають. У сусідньому селі
Рушево можна побачити, до чого це призводить.
У школі залишилося лише чотири учні,
один сьогодні відсутній через хворобу.
Першого класу цьогоріч узагалі нема.
Така ситуація тут уперше.
- Цей шкільний рік для нас епохальний, бо в нас
уперше менше, ніж 5 учнів. Але нашу школу не закриють.
Навпаки, місцева влада ремонтує цю школу,
навіть якщо невідомо, для кого.
Школу з двома вчительками та чотирма дітьми.
- Де є школа, є й життя. Діти йдуть через село,
і все виглядає зовсім інакше. Це наша позиція,
тому ми ремонтуємо всі сільські школи.
Але для кого? Понад половина будинків
уздовж центральної сільської вулиці порожні,
багато з них руйнуються.
Цьому дідусю вже за 90.
Він каже, окрім нього та його сусідки на цій вулиці
нікого більше не залишилося.
- Коли я був молодий, я приносив старим дрова,
косив траву або допомагав на тракторі. Але тепер
тут нікого більше нема, хто міг би мені допомогти. Нікого!
У Буку ситуація ще не настільки драматична.
Поки що. Маріяна дуже довго шукала в селі роботу,
однак безрезультатно. І вона не єдина.
Сім'ї з цих трьох будинків уже виїхали за кордон.
У Німеччину.
Економіка Хорватії роками переживає важку кризу,
зарплати низькі. Молоді та освічені люди
виїжджають і забирають із собою свої сім'ї.
Підприємства, які ще залишилися, мають тепер
величезну проблему: знайти кваліфікованих працівників.
Чоловік Маріяни працював тут раніше,
аж поки не знайшов кращу роботу в Німеччині.
Керівник фірми дедалі частіше замислюється
про те, щоб узагалі закрити свій бізнес.
- У нашому регіоні, де ми працюємо й інвестуємо,
нині найбільша проблема - знайти добрих працівників.
І це залишиться незмінним.
Стєпан щовечора телефонує своїй родині.
Антонела нетерпляче чекала його дзвінка.
По-дитячому нітиться, коли бачить його на екрані мобільного.
- Як справи?
- Добре.
- У тебе все добре?
- Так.
- Це добре. А ще щось розкажеш?
- Нічого.
Діти дуже сумують за татом. Увечері часто плачуть.
Вони звикли до нього і хочуть бути біля нього,
тому ми хочемо переїхати до нього.
Ми вже три роки живемо окремо. Досить вже!
Антонелі точно досить. Їй доведеться залишити
свою бабусю, дідуся, своє село.
І тут стане ще на одну молоду сім'ю менше.